Here's my solution.
I put the strategies into a list because
we're going to be indexing into that.
I start out in the start state.
Nothing has happened. No points awarded.
Player number 0, that is "Player A,"
is the player to move. Then I repeat this loop.
Tell me everything I know about the current state.
If the score of the player whose turn it is,
is greater than the goal, then that player wins.
"Player 0" or "Player 1"--"A" or "B."
Same if the other player is greater than the goal,
then that player wins and, otherwise, I pick out the
strategy function for the player to play.
If "P" is "0," then strategy "0" is "A."
If "P" is "1," then strategy "1" is "B."
Apply that strategy function to the state
and if it's whole, I apply the hold action to the state to get a new state.
Otherwise, I assume that the strategy function is legal,
and if it doesn't return whole, then it does return roll.
I'll give it the benefit of the doubt there, and perform the roll action
on the state and on a random integer from 1 to 6, inclusive.
That will give me the new state, and I continue until we find a winner.